good morning hey how's it going it's
beautiful
god it's so awkward to vlog in public I
hate it so I'm doing another vlog today
because you both really like the last
one so this is the last day of me being
in Tokyo I figured I'll do another vlog
mainly because when I get home I'm not
gonna want to film a video guys I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna want to sleep
alright say we should do some fun stuff
today since the last day we're saving up
everything that we haven't done yet and
I'm gonna have to stop vlogging before I
get run over by a bike okay bye my
laptop just got a lot cooler oh yeah
I mean why guys did you open the door
damn it it's been a week with these
[ __ ] we are walking to the station
and I don't know why I'm blowing at this
but now you know
well it's closed where do we go now
I'm vlogging I don't care about telling
you guys yes it's closed
whatever I mean I guess we can just
climb across I'm just going almost there
okay so then the pot everything is
closed because it's a national holiday
so we decided to go to a cemetery
which is also closed let's not go then
Tim it even dead people need breaks this
guy coughed right in our face and then
took off on a boat and now we're
following him because it's what we do
[ __ ] that's right what a dick
what is he doing that he can hear us oh
my god he's still there
probably coughing away
Oh
what's up guys I'm Ethan Bradberry oh my
god we're having so much fun oh wait
there's PJ what a loser I mean then
update I'm going to eat this fish it
doesn't look like a fish Oh
not some Ethan Bradberry [ __ ] right
there hey what are you doing huh right
now I thought you might want if I told
you not being my camera I thought you
might want to feed ya get a shot of this
no get out of my shot
get out of my shots PJ uh-huh I made
them properly
no not yeah yes yes oh nice oh my god we
got the donor laughter I've looked
everywhere for it so I'm looking for
items four five word stuff Japan I want
to make a Japan Edition and I think I'm
in the right place guys I found the best
thing ever it's a costume hi guys where
are we going
yeah the hair the lab it's gonna be
24-hour let's go again
it's gonna be a good show I'm gonna
enjoy think I'll enjoy if I look if I
look that dead inside I'll enjoy it oh
my god
tonight sit please can you sit
oh my god they move this is so exciting
hey all right that's cool what a trip
okay so what is this okay it's a jelly
shot
what do you think so far they're really
good yeah they really know how to
capitalize
holy [ __ ] guys one word why was that
like just good job shopping Shaka
Japanese that was crazy
that was the perfect way to end the
Japan trip thank you Peter
it was amazing would do again would
recommend five-star on Yelp fine Stern
yeah yeah time to head back home I'm
gonna do what I always do teleport in
three two one
I'm so tired it's 3 p.m. we just got
back such a great holiday I really
really enjoyed it
I've been to Japan before but this time
was really fun to experience it with PJ
and Sophie we had a lot of fun I'm
really glad we went with those guys and
I'm gonna try and stay awake right now
I'll probably edit the vlog alright
thank you for watching another vlog I
really enjoy that you brought I don't
know where to wash in this [ __ ]
camera I enjoy that you enjoy them and I
enjoy making them and that's all we got
to do for now and as always stay awesome